former empire actor jesse smollett is
waking up behind bars this morning after
chicago judge sentenced him to 150 days
in jail with 30 months probation for
lying after a staged hate crime against
himself he was also fined 25 thousand
dollars a jury found smug guilty on five
felony counts of disorderly conduct last
december charlie damar was at the court
i am innocent i could have said that i
was guilty a long time ago
jesse smallett maintained his innocence
on his way out of court last night
during sentencing smilet didn't make a
statement but after the judge sentenced
him to 150 days in jail he pulled down
his mask and spoke to the courtroom if i
did this then it means that i stuck my
fist in the fears of black americans in
this country for over 400 years and the
fears of the lgbtq community your very
name has become an adverb for lying
moments before judge james lynn didn't
hold back why would you betray
something like social justice issues is
profoundly arrogant and self selfish and
narcissistic that's the only thing that
can be concluded smilet claimed two
masked men beat him up yelled racial and
homophobic slurs adam and put a noose
around his neck
but abel and ola osindaro later
testified smilet paid them 3 500 dollars
to carry out the attack the chicago
police department spent more than a
thousand hours of overtime investigating
smilet's false report the investigation
cost the city roughly 130 thousand
dollars and though smilet has been
ordered to pay most of it back the
prosecution said money isn't the biggest
problem it hurt the effort
to have people come forward and report
hate crimes and that was wrong
for cbs morning's charlie demar chicago